[Aplausos]
[Música]
azerbayán es ese país que no sabías ni
que existía hasta que un día viste el
festival de eurovisión sin embargo es un
país con mucho que ofrecer al mundo si
hablamos una vez más de gas natural pero
creedme hay mucho mucho más
[Música]
vito corleone decía que la familia es
muy importante y lo cierto es que en
azerbayán han seguido su consejo la
familia alguien lo es todo en este país
[Música]
controla la política y la economía con
mano de hierro sin embargo a la hora de
negociar no coloca ni cabezas de caballo
sino caviar si habéis oído bien los
alien pueden ser corruptos y represores
con sus propios ciudadanos
pero en cuanto llega alguien del
extranjero saben tratarle como una
rockstar si de algo saben en este país
es de diplomacia y eso explica que
aunque hagan frontera con irán
azerbaiyán esté en el consejo de europa
participe una hora visión y hasta juega
en la eurocopa
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero que tiene
azerbaiyán que les hace tan atractivos
pues aparte del caviar el mar caspio
ofrece otras cosas mucho más
interesantes por ejemplo pues por
ejemplo tenemos enormes reservas de
petróleo y por supuesto gas natural y
recordáis quién necesita diversificar
sus proveedores de gas natural exacto la
unión europea si habéis visto los vídeos
anteriores de esta serie ya sabéis que
alemania finlandia y prácticamente todo
el este de europa depende muchísimo del
gas ruso
así que por muy corruptos y represores
que sean los alien a bruselas no le
queda más remedio que hacer negocios con
ellos
y ya sé lo que estáis pensando seguro
que a putin no le hace ninguna gracia
verdad a fin de cuentas a rusia le
interesa que europa dependa de su gas es
decir que eso de buscar otros
proveedores son malas noticias para el
trampolín verdad pues nada de eso como
buenos maestros de la diplomacia los a
leyes han sido capaces de caerle bien a
todo el mundo incluido a putin
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es qué
importancia tiene el régimen de bakú
para los planes del kremlin hoy vamos a
responder a esta pregunta y lo vamos a
hacer junto a nuestro buen amigo
alejandro nada más y nada menos que el
autor del canal de youtube hipótesis de
poder hola jose acá y un gran abrazo a
todos suscriptores de visual política y
sí como bien dices los aliens son unos
maestros de la diplomacia pero como
lograron aliarse con putin ya la vez con
la unión europea que tiene que ver
ucrania con todo esto pues ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
en la diplomacia del caviar mayo de 2014
el uruguayo diego godín acaba de marcar
el gol que hace campeón de la liga de
fútbol española al atletico de madrid
millones de espectadores en todo el
mundo ven en su camiseta que está
escrito
azerbaiyán land of fire
así fue durante todos los partidos del
atlético de madrid entre el año 2012 y
el año 2015 y os preguntaréis porque un
país como azerbaiyán se gasta la
friolera de 24 millones de euros en
publicidad en fin conoces a mucha gente
que se haya ido de turismo azerbayán yo
tampoco obviamente la respuesta no tiene
nada que ver con el turismo contable del
año 2009 en la guerra del gas entre
ucrania y rusia dejó a muchos países
europeos sin calefacción
[Música]
en ese momento en europea buscó otras
alternativas al gas ruso y qué pasaba
mientras en azerbaiyán pues queda el año
2006 centrado en operaciones el
megayacimiento es a denis con reservas
suficientes para reducir la dependencia
rusa en un 10% es decir que europa
estaba como loca buscando proveedores y
azerbaiyán buscando compradores el amor
estaba en el aire pero como sabéis en el
juego del amor a veces necesitamos un
pequeño chispazo de pasión y ahí es
donde entra la llamada diplomacia del
caviar veréis hacer tratos con una
dictadura no es agradable pero en bakú
la capital de azerbaiyán tiene el dinero
para eso y más que nadie quiero
organizar los juegos europeos porque
sólo una especie de juegos olímpicos
pero sólo para europa y no tiene ningún
sentido económico pues no pasa nada hay
esta azerbayán poniendo sus petrodólares
que valencia epicentro de los casos de
corrupción de españa deja de organizar
el gran premio de europa de fórmula uno
no pasa nada hay está azerbayán con sus
petrodólares que hacen falta
patrocinadores para el eurocopa
no pasa nada ahí está azerbaiyán con sus
petrodólares da igual que sea la marca
azerbaiyán land of fire o simplemente la
marca soc arh que es la empresa
petrolera de este país lo cierto es que
el dinero y el caviar de los alien están
en todas partes y eso explica noticias
como esta
euro 2020 prepárate para partidos desde
bilbao hasta bakú efectivamente la
próxima eurocopa disputarán los de
países europeos y azerbaiyán ha sido uno
de los países elegidos por delante de
otros como yo con tradición futbolística
como bulgaria o suecia y con este tipo
de eventos
azerbayán ha conseguido lavar su imagen
y comprar voluntades gracias a esto es
como nadie pone la más mínima pega para
construir todos los gasoductos
necesarios
[Música]
en primer lugar está el gasoducto del
campo stosur una tubería para llevar el
gas del yacimiento al mar caspio a
territorio turco a través de georgia
funciona desde el año 2006
[Música]
no piensen que estaba borracho que tras
el gas absoluto armenia y azerbaiyán se
llevan peor q cryer rusia así que era
mejor dar un rodeo por georgia pero
también hay un segundo absoluto el de
naves que llega hasta grecia y se
inauguró este año pero el proyecto final
se llama el tav y llegaría hasta italia
y os preguntaréis putin que que piensa
putin de todo esto pues en principio no
le hizo la más mínima gracia es más
intentó evitar que el gas de azerbaiyán
llegar a italia por todos los medios
recordáis que el hombre de putin en
berlín es el ex canciller gerhard
schröder pues el hombre de putin en
roma' es nada menos que bp grilo del
movimiento 5 estrellas
el gobierno de eeuu advierte italia
tengan cuidado hay relación entre rusia
y el movimiento cinco estrellas y todo
esto explica que bp grilo soltará
declaraciones como esta
si vienen a hacer el oleoducto puzzle a
desde cualquier lugar incluso con el
ejército pondremos a nuestro ejército
también sin embargo vamos a pasarlo
justo aquí estas declaraciones son del
año 2014 sin embargo ahora estamos en el
año 2018 4 años dan para mucho así que
vamos a acelerar un poquito el tiempo
hasta llegar a nuestros días
[Música]
y todo queda en casa toda dinastía tiene
a su patriarca y la historia de haidar
alien es impresionante empezó siendo un
espía de la calle y estuvo 25 años
jugando a ser el james bond de bakú en
1969 press net le nombró líder de la
república soviética de azerbaiyán en los
años 80 ascendió al politburó del
kremlin hasta que chocó con gorbachov
en 1991 azerbayán logró obtener su
independencia y en dos años ayudar a
liberar al presidente con estar atentos
98 8% de los votos
haidar era un hombre pragmático y menos
un año había firmado un alto al fuego
con armenia y lo que se conoce como el
contrato del siglo
la británica bp las americanas exxon y
chevron la noruega statoil nadie se
quería la posibilidad de perder explotar
el crudo del mar caspio azerbaiyán se
reservaba un 80% de los beneficios de
hecho se acuerdan cuál es la primera
imagen de james bond en azerbayán en el
mundo nunca es suficiente conducir un
coche entre pozos petrolíferos así que
la economía de azerbayán va como un tiro
petróleo gas y caviar el país crece y la
corrupción también todo queda en familia
ya lo decía vito corleone un hombre que
no pasa tiempo con su familia no puede
ser un hombre así que a la muerte del
patriarca heydar alíyev en 2003 todo
estaba atado y bien atado para que su
hijo iljam alíev fuera el heredero
[Música]
gana las elecciones con un 75% de los
votos pero en dictaduras así con el
tiempo hemos aprendido que el porcentaje
es lo de menos
[Música]
books azerbaiyán dio a conocer los
resultados antes de que la votación
hubiera comenzado a mal y yerno se corta
un pelo eliminó de la constitución el
límite de los mandatos presidenciales y
ha colocado a su mujer de vicepresidenta
cargo creado por y para ella y también
ha eliminado la edad mínima de 35 años
de los candidatos para poder ocupar la
presidencia por qué pues porque su hijo
varón aún tiene 21 años y bueno pues
nunca se sabe por supuesto todo el que
se mueve contra los alíyev acaba entre
rejas los anillos mientras tanto se han
hecho millonarios os acordáis de los
papeles de panamá pues sí parece que con
la ayuda del despacho de mimosa fonseca
los alien montaron un auténtico imperio
y no por si alguien se lo estaba
preguntando moza fonseca no tiene nada
que ver con mi familia
el caso es y qué haces cuando tienes
dinero pues lo usas para hacer amigos
la investigación sobre corrupción en el
consejo de europa sobre azerbaiyán pero
ya lo sé todavía no hemos contestado a
la pregunta que han hecho en azerbaiyán
para llevarse bien con vladimir putin
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
realismo político michael corleone lo
sabía ten cerca a tus amigos pero más
cerca a tus enemigos y si recordáis
vladimir putin tiene dos objetivos
[Música]
1 vender gas a europa y 2 aislar
económicamente a ucrania las guerras del
gas impulsarán el gasoducto nord stream
1 y nord stream 2 que manda el gas ruso
hasta alemania por el báltico pero claro
eso no es suficiente necesitan nuevas
tuberías para terminar de aislar a
ucrania sin embargo no creáis que
construir en europa es tan fácil no me
creéis pues mirad de esta noticia
[Música]
suspende el proyecto de gasoducto south
stream a diferencia de ser vayan a putin
no se da muy bien la diplomacia la
invasión rusia de crimea provoca una
serie de sanciones que se llevaron por
adelante el gasoducto que se había
propuesto desde el kremlin así que putin
se dio cuenta que tenía que armarse de
una mejor estrategia política y
pensándolo mejor el soft francas
corridos les va muy bien ya que es
europa está invirtiendo en el sur para
recibir y casas de azerbaiyán el gas les
puede llegar hasta allí
[Música]
y ese es el objetivo del gasoducto que
rusia construyó bajo el mar negro el
torso firme una tubería enorme que no
sólo sirve para suministrar el gas a
turquía pero para suministrarlo a toda
europa en otras palabras la jugada de
rusia es la siguiente ellos llevan el
gas a turquía y de ahí ese gas se podría
enchufar alta que llega hasta italia es
decir que esa tubería que se había
diseñado para el gas de azerbaiyán ahora
también podría llevar gas ruso
[Música]
en otras palabras que alguien ya no es
una amenaza para putin sino una
oportunidad las cosas ha cambiado en
rusia y por supuesto también han
cambiado en italia recordáis que os
decía que el movimiento cinco estrellas
estaba totalmente en contra del tav en
el año 2014 pues ahora que están en el
gobierno han dado un giro de 180 grados
a su postura
[Música]
y mayo el tav no es estratégico pero
está blindado y mientras tanto tenemos a
otros dos líderes mundiales que de la
noche a la mañana se han vuelto muy pero
que muy amigos todos salen ganando la
unión europea- diversifica azerbaiyán se
forra rusia encuentra otra manera de
vender su gas en europa y ucrania todos
- ucrania que por ahora tiene un futuro
muy negro pero las preguntas ahora son
para ustedes creéis que putin conseguirá
burlarse de europa y conseguir a
circular el gas ruso por el tap
hasta cuando pensáis que los alien
podrán manejar a azerbaiyán como si
fuera su empresa familiar y lo que es
más importante cómo creéis que acabará
todo esto para ucrania
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y por supuesto no olvidéis
visitar el canal hipótesis de poder
donde también se habla de geopolítica y
de relaciones internacionales y como
siempre si os ha gustado este vídeo
suscribiros a visual político y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]